what's going on everybody and welcome to
part 16 of the Python hey i in starcraft
2 tutorial series in this video we're
gonna be doing is working over some of
the visualization changes that we would
like to make here so one we definitely
have new units that we need to be able
to display but also someone posed the
question to me why are we doing
you know RGB why are we doing three x's
BGR but why are we doing three channels
here
why not grayscale wouldn't that be
simpler and I didn't really have any
answer that it's so so so why not
grayscale so so I am going to just try
to do grayscale now we'll get to it but
I also really wanted to be able to do
like an alpha kind of channel but I I
just could not figure out how to do it
so if somebody has a solution to that
that'd be great
so anyways let's get started so the
first thing is we're really just gonna
be changing the intel method as soon as
i find it and basically we're just gonna
I'm just gonna clear it out we're gonna
redo basically everything here so game
data can stay will keep that so you'll
you'll note that yes we are starting
still with three channels what we're
gonna do is we're gonna do everything we
need to do and then at the very end
we'll convert it to grayscale there's
probably a better way to do that but
we're gonna do this way for now so what
we're gonna do is just begin iterating
over our units and then the enemy units
so again I'm just gonna copy and paste
these in from the text-based version
link in description and so yeah so all
we do is four units and our units what
we're going to do is we're going to grab
their position then we just draw the
circle on the game data so same thing as
before only this time we use the units
radius attribute that's like always been
there I didn't use it so thanks to our
Quyet rest's for pointing that one out
and maybe other people but that's who I
saw it from then we're gonna draw this
in all white and then this is just the
line thickness
were for the actual thing that we're
gonna draw so that's already units now
we're gonna do the exact same thing only
with the enemy units so we'll just copy
this fix this and in this case this
should just be self dot known enemy
units we grab their position we draw it
everything's the same the only
difference is I'm gonna do 125 125 125
so we are a bright white they will be a
gray now we could make this a little
more fancy and you know do different
colors for like buildings versus workers
versus military units bla bla bla bla
bla we get really advanced here for now
I'm just gonna keep it super super
simple and just see what we can how far
we can get with this also this just
creates a circle again because I
couldn't figure out the Alpha I'll
explain that a little more in depth in a
moment then we're gonna draw our
beautiful line so I'm just gonna paste
that in you've seen this code the only
thing that's changed here is it rather
than being like the military units now
it becomes a worker wait so this way I
don't have to know what are all the
military units that we have instead
we're just going to count the number of
workers because there's only a really
one worker so that's just a little
easier to keep track of there now we're
gonna finish off the code so after the
exception the exception is mostly for
div by zero issues that we're gonna get
by doing these calculations here like if
we run out of workers or you know
whatever so or I suppose this could also
equal zero anyway okay so I think I
think we're ready to actually run this
one this one already this will be a one
of the shortest tutorials ever whoa I
didn't know I was capable up film for
that same thing again let's go here I'll
bring this one over up and this time
it's part 16 visualization changes I
don't see any errors yet so thank you to
my most recent sponsors Brett
August I have no idea how to pronounce
that usually I can look up names and
figure out like how to pronounce them
and for some reason that name doesn't it
doesn't have a how to pronounce JT mojo
and Robert diamond thank you guys very
much for your support and we are off so
now you can see our visualization here
we are everything's nice and in gray
scaled and at least with the way things
are set up like right now we can see you
know I'm so bothered about you know
where was I gonna put the camera and I
completely forgot that this I haven't
been full screening the game for a while
anyway so here's our scout going in boom
we found an enemy Nexus clearly and then
a bunch of things there's all their
little workers and we're just kind of
floating about here doing who knows what
eventually we're gonna die and so yeah
so so we can clearly tell what's going
on we can see that they've already begun
expanding although I think that we're
kind of displaying things not quite
perfectly because I think we required
our units to be ready and we didn't
require their units to be ready to graph
them or I don't know display them
anyways yeah so so we can tell pretty
well our strengths we can tell that
these probably are workers they don't
take up much space we've clearly got
some buildings here I'm gonna guess
those are pylons we can we can confirm
that though they look awful close to
each other yeah oh that was the other
thing let me see if I have that actually
modified so look at how these pylons so
someone else I forget the name
I apologize but someone did point out
let's see let me go to pile on where's
our build pile on from our method rather
right so this was an interesting piece
of code that I don't think I referenced
yet if I have I apologize profusely
anyways we can build a pile of near self
dot units Nexus at the first position oh
dear I've started dragging at at the
first position towards the game map
center what an ingenious way so that
stops things from being built like we
were building a lot of buildings and
stuff in the pathway here which is
obviously pretty unfortunate you don't
really want to do that so I tested it
with pylons it works quite well we
should probably
apply that same logic to all of the
buildings because if you start building
a building here it really wastes a lot
of your time in resource collection so
anyways so the Alpha problem so ideally
these would be colored and then we can
add different colors for different types
of Units possibly but the problem is I
could find lots of ways to you know do a
single alpha channel like if you just
want to draw like a circle on the screen
and add an alpha to it that's fine but
what if you want to overlap circles with
alpha and then where they they overlap
obviously that add that's more color it
should be stronger that doesn't appear
to be possible in open CV which is
shocking but I don't think it is like I
said I can find lots of ways to give an
alpha channel to it to it to a group of
objects or they could overlap initially
and then you apply alpha but you don't
have like the brighter overlap part
anyway if someone could figure that one
out
I'd like to see it just curiously I just
I feel like that's a huge huge oversight
in open CV if that doesn't exist but
anyway well we're definitely in trouble
we have a single stalker and we're
almost 10 minutes into the game oh boy
here comes the this doesn't end well
guys oh where are they there they are a
good game all right so the visuals are
all set and basically we're ready to
start training so this was obviously
just random I can tell you right now the
media you know where we I at least I
have never witnessed a game where an AI
that makes random choices like this
beats medium it just does not happen so
so so you have to first of all compete
against the easy AI instead but I'll
talk about that and a few more things
the next tutorial talk about the
training data and all that in the
findings from running this a little
longer and with building some training
data trying out the model seeing how
things went so anyways that's what we're
gonna do in the next
video if you've got questions comments
suggestions whatever feel free to leave
them below otherwise I will see you in
another video